hey everybody it is April 2nd 2020 day 2
of 30 of the latest 30 days to stop the
spread which may not be the final 30
days to stop the spread we just don't
really know yet all we can do is take it
day by day and these streams almost
daily streams have sort of become it's
kind of like a coronavirus update day we
go through the numbers I hear from you
guys we listen to the president why we
listen to doctors mostly tell the truth
we listen to questions from journalists
that's sort of what we're doing because
we are we are all home for the most part
heard about 75% of the country
individuals now are socially distanced
physically distanced to some degree and
probably needs to be more but I actually
read an interesting study today which
says that it's 80% you need to get above
80% for the social distancing to really
work properly maybe we will get there
now with the addition of a stay at home
order in Florida and more stay at home
orders coming in other states presumably
top of the hour is when today's press
briefing is scheduled we don't know if
it will start on time or if it will not
we have three different streams that we
are monitoring primary secondary and
backup I guess is what we are calling
them volume levels and video quality
always unpredictable so I like to have
backups let's get to the latest numbers
officially as of right now 1 million
seven thousand coronavirus cases
globally we have surpassed the 50,000
death mark tragically above 52,000 at
this point in time the u.s. still by far
now leading more than double the
official cases of any other country
followed by Italy Spain Germany and
China we really at this point I just
don't know if we can trust the Chinese
numbers or not you know initially we
thought we couldn't then we were told WH
o officials are there verifying then it
seems after the Taiwan Fiasco that maybe
we can't trust WH o officials I just
don't know I think we
just have to carry forward essentially
ignoring the Chinese numbers and
focusing on the mitigation that South
Korea has been able to do consider that
South Korea got its first case within a
24-hour period of the u.s. they have
only 169 deaths all tragic but we had
over a thousand deaths yesterday they
still have only 169 very very important
stuff okay let's look at the United
States number at this point the latest
data is that we officially have 240
thousand cases 5808 deaths of course I
don't have to remind most of you that
Donald Trump said this would be washed
through like a miracle by April that
Donald Trump said we have 15 cases which
will soon be zero we have no deaths etc
we now have 5808 deaths still at this
point in time 123 thousand of the 240
right around fifty percent of the cases
are in two states
New York and New Jersey Michigan and
California both join the five digit or
more case numbers both with 10,000
Louisiana now over 9,000 Massachusetts
rapidly approaching Florida of course is
going to see huge growth Florida has 22
a population of 22 million it's a the
fifth oldest state the population of
Florida the median age is the fifth
oldest so as Florida gets more and more
cases it's going to be very ugly they
have a stay at home order starting
tomorrow from Smurf Governor Ron de
santis who just waited way way way too
long as you know it takes 10 to 14 days
for a stay at home order to be reflected
in the numbers so the next 10 to 14 days
in Florida are going to be really really
bad however on the upside it looks like
they aren't doing that much testing and
that's a great way to artificially keep
the official number of cases lower than
it is in reality really bad what we are
expecting in Florida at this point in
time the latest update on the model this
is the IH ME model from Christopher
Murray dr. Christopher Murray you
find it at kovat 19 dot health data org
this is updated every day we are now 13
days until peak resource use on April
15th April 15th is accept expected to be
the day of peak resource youth use April
16th expected to be the top death day 14
days from that now it is projected that
we will have somewhere between twelve
hundred and forty one hundred deaths on
April 16th an unconscionable number the
specifics the confidence interval the
specific number twenty six forty four
very important the peak is not one day I
know I'm saying this daily but we will
be above fifteen hundred deaths a day
according to the model between April 5
all the way to May 3rd so the peak in a
sense is going to really be almost a
month and that's extraordinarily
difficult to understand because for lots
of us it feels like we've been doing is
for so long already like we're almost
three full weeks in here in
Massachusetts something like ninety four
percent of the deaths haven't happened
yet right the feeling of wait a second
we're only six percent in and of course
because of the curve were more than six
percent in timewise hopefully but we
still have 94 percent of the deaths are
in front of us the latest total death
number 93 531 importantly this is only
the first wave we are we are expecting a
second and probably a third wave and 93
thousand deaths expected in this first
wave those numbers are updated daily and
we are looking at them with you at every
stream let me welcome everybody who is
joining me via Twitter twitch Facebook
live and of course YouTube if you're
joining on youtube remember to like the
stream and to subscribe we are expecting
the press cook briefing to start at the
top of the hour reports are that anthony
factory will not be there today we also
now have a number of reports that dr.
anthony foul he needs armed security
because listen he is a tiny 17
year-old doctor trying to save lives of
course trumpets are sending him death
threats it is in it it's one of the most
depressing little factoids of this
entire thing that he needs armed
security and I have I have a whole story
about that today on the on my on my
youtube channel forthcoming so I won't
spend too much time on that let me say a
few thank-yous to people who are sending
super chats inconsolable says David is a
Navy veteran I'm disgusted with how the
Navy has treated not only the situation
but the hero CEO who brought attention
to the dire situation he has been fired
it's a disgrace yes it is name withheld
says hey David what kind of veggies do
you recommend this year thinking about
zucchini and yellow squash do you mean
what veggies do I recommend eating or
growing eating I mean they're all so
good growing I am soon going to be
planning some peppers snow peas gonna be
doing my my tomatoes of course there's
videos on my on my Instagram of my
tomato harvesting from last season I'm
in touch with a friend who has multiple
very strong degrees in vegetable growing
essentially I mean we're talking about
you know agriculture and so on and so
forth and he is guiding me via zoom
socially distanced of course in getting
my garden going and I'll keep you guys
posted
Jamal Swift says hey homie had to take a
break in order to regain optimism but
I'm back how do you protect your mental
health through all of this meditation
etc yes meditation trying to take
scheduled breaks from it so like last
week Friday Saturday I just stayed away
from everything no live streaming that
as little as possible red played
keyboard played drums
ran stuff like that I will probably do
it again this weekend Danny Thompson
says living in Minnesota like being in
another world governor Walt started the
daily briefing by thanking the press for
their great questions every day to keep
them going
imagine that Ian says please make a
cameo account cameo has been trying to
recruit me but I just I don't want to
spread myself too thin sensible talk
says smash that like button folks yes
please smash the like button smash the
subscribe button Donna Williams says
David have you read the book the cult of
Trump no I have not I try to avoid
political books to be perfectly honest I
get enough politics researching the show
hound dog says Tennessee Governor is
signing a stay at home order today glad
to hear it
that's what needs to happen let me say a
few thank-yous for people signing up on
my website Dennis Williams is new member
number one today Jeremy wrench is new
member number two and KC McNeely is new
member number three oh so listen to this
there has been made I'll tell you guys a
story because we're just we're just
standing by here we have had a crazy 24
hours here at the show so yesterday I
explained on stream when we had it was
later into the stream so we had more
people watching than we do right now
yesterday I explained everybody's
tightening their belts in March we lost
a record number of members I you know
I'm well beyond just pretending like
everything's just peachy keen we had
three hundred and eighty nine members
cancel memberships in March normally I
want to be talking to you about how many
people subscribed instead three hundred
and eighty nine people canceled
membership so yesterday on stream I said
listen I don't want your last two bucks
but if you're in a financial position
where you can support the work that we
are doing this would be a great time to
do it go to join pakman.com grab a
membership coupon code is up there so
many people did it at once that our
entire website crashed and not for five
minutes
for like 50 the better part of 50
minutes only working intermittently
during the stream and this is all
recorded on yesterday's video I was
sending messages to our web developer
she was sending messages to our
performance consultant and they were
feverishly I would even say fever ently
they were look that one up on urban
dictionary they were urgently trying to
get the web web site to come back up and
with only sporadic website functionality
we had like 37 people or so who grabbed
memberships yesterday and I said to them
listen guys how many people try
to sign up during the stream they say it
looks like it was it was probably close
to 150 people of course we were all on
the same page like we can't have the web
we can't lose a hundred memberships
because the website crashed like we need
we need that working so from yesterday
to today there have been many hours many
man and woman hours our web developers
is a woman trying to increase resources
on the website which we have now doubled
overnight so once again I will mention
this is a great time to get a membership
at join pakman.com we did lose three
hundred and eighty nine members in march
worst month that we've had as far as
that goes the coupon code twenty twenty
now makes a monthly membership two bucks
a month a yearly membership is twenty
bucks for the year like a dollar eighty
three a month very very inexpensive and
let's test the website I now have a
whole panel in front of me which and
they are monitoring it which shows
resource usage CPU usage and all sorts
of stuff and we need it to work right
now it's nice and steady at 13% CPU
usage and it looks like there are 12
people right now in somewhere in the
sign-up process so let's test it and we
we really need it to work so it'll be an
exciting we've got a lot of people
keeping an eye on on what's going on let
me say thank you to free Hong Kong for
for signing up with twitch prime gold
and Jericho has subscribed rach23 has
subscribed okay let's get to something
fun okay during the State of the Union I
published on Twitter a Donald Trump
bingo card we now are going to develop a
coronavirus press briefing bingo card
for Trump now we're not this is just
because we're doing something okay
we are not minimizing the seriousness of
coronavirus we're not doing anything
other than everybody's going crazy so we
want to develop a bingo card so a viewer
of mine sent me some ideas for the bingo
card I'm gonna tell you what they are
you guys can then suggest additional
elements for the bingo card we will put
it together we can all play along in the
future
okay so here are the some ideas for the
Donald Trump press briefing bingo card
um I know blank better than anyone
right so Trump will say I know South
Korea better than anyone I know blank
better than anyone the country is meant
to be open blaming Obama and that
includes using the term inherited
because he talks about we inherited XY
that's code for Obama not taking
responsibility for something when asked
saying that we are looking at it we are
looking at it anytime anybody asks a
question Trump doesn't really know he
says we're looking at that saying a
question is nasty
saying that something like you've never
seen before is going on saying that a
question is unfair using the phrase many
people have said saying that something
is being done very strongly saying oh
visibly sweating usually by the end of
the press conference
Trump's upper lip is very very sweaty
visibly sweaty so visibly sweating could
be a square um saying I knew everything
when he's asked about when he learned
about something or did he not know
saying he knew everything
calling someone in the crowd fake news
saying that we either have done the most
or have the best tests for coronavirus
using the term high marks to refer to
his own performance or grading himself
an A or a ten out of ten that I think is
like one square it relates to grading
himself using the term elements and
using the word tremendous way which I
see a lot of people have have included
there so let me know in the chat okay
yeah touching or fiddling with the mic
that's a good one let me see what oh yes
when he says fast fast when he talks
about how quickly things are gonna get
going again that's a good one
oh the term ratings yeah the term
ratings might be a good one then we'll
vote on these and figure out which ones
we actually want to use this is just
like a big oh it was a great or perfect
call that's a good one I'm taking notes
China in a strangely pronounced way I
like that that's good
mentioning bowing yeah I don't know I'll
met I'll put it down
I don't know if that one is gonna make
the final cut mentioning Boeing is good
oh saying scourge and pronouncing it
scourge SK Oh RJ that's a good one
mentioning Walmart isn't a bad idea I
like that this is great I don't even
have to think hard about it you guys
just do it for me
best and most tests in the world I have
already nasty we know oh no one could
have known that's a good one no one
could have known that's good
pronouncing plasma as plasma yep that's
good too plasma although that's
happening less mentioning chloroquine
I'm unsure about because like that's
actually I mean I I want to be really
careful about the chloroquine thing oh
that war language yeah war this is war
war references of different kinds
mentioning governors okay that could
work saying someone is a great guy oh
industry yeah that weird pronunciation
of industry I don't know if that Oh
invisible enemy invisible enemy slash
scourge that's good it will go away
complimenting Oh a n well Oh a n got
kicked out of the probe though of the
room by the White House Correspondents
Association so I don't know that he's
going to be praising them too much fake
news CN and we have unprecedented yeah
unprecedented is good okay I've got like
fifty now
so I'll start work shopping something
and figure out what what makes the most
sense so usually the square in the
middle is a free one but I almost feel
like you don't really need a free square
like tremendous could be the middle
square he's gonna say it every time it
might we might as well not lose the
middle Square to free because he's using
it every single time alright let's see
how the website is holding up we
currently have according to what I'm
seeing fourteen people in the process of
signing up for memberships let's see how
the server is holding up it is pushed up
to ok so we're up to 38% CPU usage
yesterday when people tried to get
memberships it instantly
to a hundred percent CPU usage and the
entire thing was shut down so I'm
pleased if we can stay at 38% CPU usage
I'm actually sort of pleased to see
those numbers and let me thank some
people by the way as people are starting
signing up here let me see here okay
Marnie Evans is new member number for
today thanks Marnie
Raymond Sola is new member number five
thanks Raymond Erik c'mere
is new member number six Laurie Cox is
new member number seven Dave brat is new
member number eight
Danny Aaron brink I'm feeling good about
my pronunciations today Danny Aaron
brink Stacy Smith these are simple Stacy
thank you you were new member number ten
Terri Morgan is new member number eleven
yawns Kohler that now it's getting dicey
yawns Kohler is new member number twelve
Brett Ennis is new member number
thirteen and natty back Steve natty back
Steve is new member number fourteen
unclear if that is a legal name or or
not okay let's see here let's get to
some more super chats as they continue
to come in this is not an alias says I
live in Florida my nephew is
immunocompromised I hope Rhonda Santa's
mother is disappointed in him but I
doubt it fear Tech says thank you from
Australia thank you from the United
States Ma Scott says I have a nurse
friend who volunteered to go to New York
City and she said the on staff nurses
were crying with relief when the
volunteers walked in I've been reading
some of those reports as well horrible
horrible horrible horrible what is what
is going on right now
Zachary Monroe says hey Zach I am
spending my 19th birthday watching my
favorite pundit I am here at almost
every stream I love the work you and
your team does to keep us all informed
hashtag support for the David Pakman
show
hashtag love for the Pakman Zachary
happy birthdays
axé been a fixture at my streams since
months ago and it's always great to see
you also thanks to newpsie Chapin for
the soy boys subscription ryan nawicki
says have you made any investments since
the drop in the market metals stocks and
others are prime for some level savvy of
investment stay safe David yeah I mean
I'll tell you some of the investments I
made let's pull up Yahoo Finance here
and we'll see together how they did
today I made a couple of different moves
so today is an upmarket day so we'll see
so one thing I did was I did by Roku
I think Roku you know I've owned Netflix
for years I think Roku whoops Roku is
likely to do what do well is people are
staying home up just a little bit today
and yeah it dipped pretty low there so I
bought Roku I bought Live Nation the
idea being they're gonna get crushed for
now ooh brutal down 12% today but that
eventually right around this time is
when I got in that eventually live
events are going to come back I got some
bear because they are one of the
chloroquine makers and sort of maybe
chloroquine is gonna be something who
really knows what else did I get I did
buy a little bit of Bitcoin there's one
I'm forgetting wait so Roku Live Nation
oh right and I also got zoom because a
lot of people are using zoom now and
it's down pretty big today but it's been
it's been up quite a bit since all of
this stuff started so these are sort of
like you know long plays as many of you
know I don't really like trade stocks in
any real way I'm sort of a buy and hold
buy and hold sort of guy if you're just
joining us on on YouTube please remember
hit the like button and hit the
subscribe button it it's free and it
really supports the work that we are
doing Bigley okay I've got a couple
other things to show you Donald Trump
tweeted earlier just spoke to my friend
Mohammed bin Salman the crown prince of
Saudi Arabia who
spoke with President Putin of Russia and
I expect and hope they will be cutting
back approximately 10 million barrels
and maybe substantially more which if it
happens will be great for the oil and
gas industry the president is publicly
bragging about working with Russia and
the Saudis to make oil more expensive
which will make gas more expensive sit
back for a second close your eyes and
imagine that it was discovered back in
2013 that Barack Obama called up the
Saudis and called the Putin and said
guys let's work together to make oil
more expensive it would be 24 hours a
day on Fox
Rush Limbaugh Mark Levin you know they
would all be saying this is treason and
the man must go we just found out
because Trump said it out loud
Trump is telling us I'm trying to raise
the price of oil by colluding with the
Saudis and the Russians these are insane
times absolutely insane times the FDA
has authorized the first coronavirus
antibody test this is very good news
unfortunately this is a test that can't
be done with a pinprick and just the
tiny bit of blood this is a test that
requires you to go in and have a
phlebotomist draw blood and of course
that's the last place anybody should be
going right now
anybody who can should be avoiding going
anywhere where germs could be could
could be spread and thus it is
interesting and it is good that there is
an antibody test coming but it is not
practical for us to be relying on on a
test like that at this point in time
lastly here is video of Seema Burma
Burma
sorry Seema Burma well she is not a
doctor as I once incorrectly identified
her here she is explaining that the
reason we suck at coronavirus is we are
a free country
here's Seema referring to when he says
the best model we have for America is
what's happened in Italy well I think
that if you look at these other
countries if you look at China and South
Korea right though they had very
different approaches we're a free
country we're giving recommendations to
the American people and hoping that
they're going to adhere to those in
terms of what happened in Italy the
strain on the healthcare system those
are the things that the lessons that we
are trying to learn from we're trying to
prepare our health care system some of
the the recent regulations that we
pulled back from just earlier this week
are going to have a really big impact on
our health care system it's giving them
that flexibility at the local level
saying the problem the reason that we
are sucking more than South Korea for
example is that we are a free country
and they are not now so South Korea is
quite a free country if you actually
look at look at freedom indices but then
she says and what we're doing is we're
gonna make the country more free in the
sense of letting corporations do
whatever the hell they want we're going
to have more deaths because we are a
free country and we're reducing
regulations making it as they would
frame it and even for your country but
they're expecting that that will turn
around
the death toll in some way it's
inconceivable acrobatics mental
acrobatics that these people are doing
on a daily basis and we I mean we're
just we're being failed by this
leadership if you can even call it that
the best news of the day and this is not
any kind of commentary on anything other
than how bad Trump is at this stuff
yesterday Trump said he'd be willing to
talk to Joe Biden about coronavirus and
the plan Joe Biden said he'd be willing
to talk to Trump and today the Trump
campaign has announced I'm sorry the
Biden campaign has announced they are
working on setting up that phone call
with Donald Trump it can only help guys
at this point in time it can only help
let me say a few other thank-yous to
people signing up on my website Rachel
Susa is new member number 15 today at
join pakman.com Liberty Bishop is new
member number 16 at join pakman.com
David R Burke is new member number 17
today Anthony Sanchez
his new member number 18 at join
pakman.com and Steve rushing is new
member number 19 so a lot of people
emailed me after yesterday's Fiasco on
stream yesterday when I mentioned 389
people canceled memberships in March and
we could really use your support like a
hundred and fifty people at once tried
to go and get a membership and the
entire website crashed we have deployed
double the bandwidth and CPU power power
to the website overnight and I am
pleased to tell you that for now things
are holding steady even though 19 people
signed up in a pretty short amount of
time our server is running at 31% CPU
usage right now it looks like there's 22
people somewhere in the signup process
and it's holding very steady and it
looks like it's functioning well so so
far so good
we have unleashed additional elements of
CPU processing power and and it is
holding steady so consider yourself
invited to go and grab a membership let
me also say thanks to I am Compu bear
for supporting us on Twitch ok let's go
back to Super chats here juni McGraw
says favorite Shakespeare book mine is
Twelfth Night you know I do so much
reading but I am NOT a Shakespeare
connoisseur I would not be positioned I
have not read Shakespeare since college
and I would be lying if I told you I had
a favorite book bulkier writer says
would you moderate a debate between Kyle
and destiny sure set it up and I will do
it
and rouvaun's as well as Mindy mcnamer
Oh McNamara have grabbed youtube
memberships classy Andy says someone
tweeted a map of the flights in US
airspace compared to Europe I was
flabbergasted flights are still
happening much more there than here I
haven't looked at that but I will take a
look Anthony foul she says 2015 dave
rubin i love Bernie Sanders 2020 Dave
Rubin Bernie Sanders and socialism will
kill millions thoughts on Reubens
political changes listen I the
we are at too important of a time to
spend time talking about dave rubin i
have a number of different videos on my
website about what I believe about dave
rubin i don't really believe that he had
this political awakening at close to 40
years of age I've talked about it before
let's not waste any more time on that
incredible TV says bingo card is missing
wacky question from Oh a n o en got
kicked out of the briefing room which is
why I think it might be a waste of a
bingo square to include Oh a n in it
because as far as I know that they're
banned they've been banned Jed has
grabbed a YouTube membership love
inspired says we're doing a good job
millions or billions yeah we have good
job on here already millions billions
could be a good one for the bingo card
we'll have to review I've got looks like
forty or fifty suggestions I will
evaluate all the best ones and tweet out
a bingo card maybe tomorrow
Bailey twenty says oh sorry hold on
where'd that go
Bailey twenty says David can you further
explain how a OCS change in tactics will
benefit the progressive movement I have
a video on that which I published
yesterday and so I don't I don't want to
like redo videos during the streams mary
dee has grabbed a youtube membership
Shannon Venice says Candace Owens is a
raging corona denier she blocked me on
Twitter so I people keep telling me what
Candice Owens has been saying but I have
no idea because she blocked both of you
know our show account and my personal
account both of them are blocked on
Twitter very sad very very sad Sam Dean
says I can't find any literature on how
kovat 19 actually kills people is it
heart failure lung collapse seems the
data just isn't being released odd we'll
know it's respiratory so people are
either essentially unable to get the
oxygen that they need and you know you
die if you don't get enough oxygen it
can also cause organ failure from organs
not getting enough oxygen so it's
essentially it's its death from
pneumonia which afflicts elderly folks
more often than younger folks that is
the mechanism as far as the reports I've
read Stu guys says rent freeze in Salt
Lake City Utah until May 15th that's a
good move a necessary one quite frankly
Maddie ice PVD says Carol Baskin created
coronavirus yeah I just finished
watching Tiger King yesterday I was
talking to my mom on the phone today and
I said she said should I watch it and I
said listen for sociological purposes
it's compelling I don't know that you're
gonna love it
but I would say check it out and and
kind of see what it does for you and go
from there it will expose you to this
disgusting underbelly people where it's
like who could you even who even
imagined that people like this exist in
this country in the world but they do so
yeah check that out I finished that up
I'm watching Ozark season three I'm
watching the better call Saul season
that's currently airing on cable I think
that's season five what else am i
watching just finished watching a
Hunters on Amazon Prime excellent show
I'm gonna be watching unorthodox on
Netflix and it was also recommended to
me to watch Geary [ __ ] which is a
Japanese show yeah that's what I've got
planned for my quarantine face let me
say a few other thank-yous to people who
are signing up on our website which is
performing beautifully right now Anders
Johnson is new member number 20 today
URI Bruce is new member number 21
Jeffery passage is new member number 22
Gavin Murray is new member number 23
today Gregory Smith is new member number
24 Jennifer katsu is new member number
25 so you know as I like to say let's go
for 50 and see if we can do it Jacob
Johansson has upgraded his subscription
I'm gonna count it as a new one why not
Alice Guo is new
number 27 today Thank You Alice crystal
Parker hey crystal great to see you new
member number 28
Steven Dunkel is new member number 29
and Erik Lavin ear or Levani eh
Erik I feel good about is new member
number 30 today I also want to say
thanks to Sebastian Lofgren who's new
member number 31 guys I have to tell you
we have two elements of our team that
are closely monitoring website
performance it is holding beautifully
what a difference a day makes yesterday
the website crashing instantly when I
mentioned membership CPU usage is
climbing we're up to 41 percent riding a
little hotter now but so far excellent
excellent website performance and our
team is truly to be commended so far
thank you okay Charlie for the bingo
card when Trump does this whole Sur
thing oh the sir routine yeah I'm gonna
put that so if people aren't familiar
with this Trump does a routine where he
will recount a story of someone coming
to him to tell him something and the way
he always tells it is he'll say you know
the doctors came to me and they said sir
that whole thing where it's like did
they read is that really how it all went
down or did like your chief of staff
come to you and say hey here's what
someone said it it strikes me as
completely insincere but what we call
the sir routine I think would be a good
thing on our on our bingo card if you're
just joining us on Twitter and Facebook
live welcome we are standing by now 18
minutes beyond the scheduled time for
today's press briefing reports are that
Anthony Fucci will not be at today's
press briefing he does now have armed
security due to the number of Trumpets
threats against him we're [ __ ] right
so that's the message that I get when a
doctor who's 79 five and a half feet
tall and is trying to save lives needs
armed security 24 hours a day not good
not good if you're joining us on Twitch
make sure to follow my channel on Twitch
dr. Goldie has just subscribed on Twitch
which I very much appreciate if you're
joining me on YouTube welcome make sure
that you're hitting that like button as
soon as you come in and I suggest
hitting the subscribe button as well a
lot of people are talking about like
like like nobody's talking about
subscribe and we're looking at subscribe
very very strongly okay
I hate juice sends a super chap waffles
derp awful says I'm immunosuppressed got
a cold no fever so far sorry to hear
that stay healthy stay healthy
David Adam says I sanitized the like
button for everyone exactly it's ready
to be pressed
go right ahead folks anthony foul she
says studies say medicare for all will
save trillions in health care
expenditures what evidence is there that
the tax increases will be less you know
I have hours of content about the cost
of Medicare for all I don't want to RIF
because it's an issue that requires
precision check out some of my videos on
my youtube channel about that Adam
Kennedy says David I will pay for five
memberships for members that watch your
show but have to cancel membership due
to coronavirus troubles you know one of
my viewers wrote me today and said David
listen I'm already a member I would love
if there was a way to easily gift a
membership to somebody else so here's
the idea I had we could start to develop
a list of people's names and email
addresses that want a free membership
and can't afford one right
anytime someone writes to me and says
hey I'd like to get five memberships for
people I send them five names and email
addresses they go on our website and buy
the membership for someone that person
boomed like magic gets notified you now
have a david pakman show membership
there may be something to this idea we
just have to kind of keep the logistics
you know I don't want to be full-time
like having to write these easy it's
just it could be a lot of logistics it's
an idea the other idea would be like
some
Google Doc but I don't want to be daxing
people I don't want to be putting you
know how do you do it I don't know
exactly but we want to develop a system
for sure
waffles jirafa says Bing Bing bong Bing
go there you go
michael says people still look up to
this guy he called it a hoax it's very
sad
here's menu tchen oh boy if minuchin is
here you know it's gonna be ugly let me
say a few other thank-yous let me see
here
Laura Hopkins is new member number 32
today at join pakman.com sean safeand is
new member number 33
kitty aguilar is new member number 34
and I will I will keep thanking folks
after here our Trump and pence thank you
very much spread Sarika faces we make
over the next four weeks we'll have
countless American lives saved we're
going to save a lot of American lives
and we're in control of our own fate
very much so maintaining social distance
practicing vigorous hygiene and staying
at home are your most effective ways to
win the war and to escape danger while
you're fighting this battle from home
we're working with the best scientists
doctors and researchers anywhere in the
world we're racing to develop new ways
to protect against the virus as well as
therapies treatments and ultimately a
vaccine and we're making a lot of
progress
I think medically a lot of progress at
the same time we're also racing to get
relief to American workers and small
businesses as you know I want to remind
small-business owners across America
that the paycheck protection program is
launching tomorrow
nearly 350 billion dollars in loans will
be let me see if we've got a better
sound level over here American workers
and small businesses as you know I want
to remind small-business owners across
America that the Paycheck protection
program is launching tomorrow nearly
three hundred and fifty billion dollars
in loans will be available to small
businesses including sole proprietors
these loans are up to 100 percent
forgivable as long as employers keep
paying their workers gotta take care of
your workers furthermore we want Social
Security beneficiaries to know that if
they are typically not required to file
a tax return they don't have to file one
in order to receive the direct cash
payments that will soon be distributed
to American citizens the Treasury will
deposit the money directly into the bank
accounts and don't forget I will always
protect your Social Security your
Medicare and your Medicaid we're
protecting Social Security Medicare and
Medicaid and I always will
I'd like now to invite SBA administrator
Jovita Carranza is doing a fantastic job
actually if you want to hear this
because I'm planning on doing an
instructional video on how to apply for
that small business thing to say a few
words about these vital initiatives and
then we'll get on to the attack of the
virus itself and please if I might stave
in Jovita thank you
Thank You mr. president and mr. vice
president secretary notion Ivanka Trump
and all who I have been working closely
with in this effort oh God
small business is the backbone of the
American economy and the president has
put the nation's 30 million small
businesses front and center in the
response effort and we are working hard
to get money to them quickly this is an
unprecedented effort by this
administration to support small
businesses and we know that there will
be challenges in the process
secretary minuchin and I are working in
tandem to ensure that feedback from our
partners is being heard and implemented
the private and public sector must work
closely together to ensure that small
businesses and their workers across the
country are put first this
administration believes wholeheartedly
that if you are a small business you are
a critical part of the economic fabric
of this country and your viability is
critical to the economic well-being of
your employees at SBA we are working
around the clock to support small
businesses ensuring that we are
prioritizing emergency capital for small
businesses that are suffering economic
harm as a result of this unprecedented
situation this relief will help
stabilize a small business sector by
providing businesses with the financial
resources they need to keep their
workers employed and keep up with their
day-to-day operating expenses today I
want to ensure that small businesses all
over the country know about the paycheck
protection program and how they can
benefit from this simply put the
Paycheck protection program is to help
keep employees on payroll and small
businesses open SBA will forgive the
portion of the loan that is used toward
job retention and certain other expenses
right we are working closely with
lenders so that businesses can go
directly to their local lenders paycheck
protection program
is in addition to substantial work that
the SBA has and will continue to do to
help small businesses including
providing advances on SBA disaster loans
and forgiving existing SBA loan payments
over the next six months additional
details on these critically important
programs can be found at sba.gov and we
will be updating these resources
regularly our hearts go out to those
affected by this terrible virus our
communities around the country are
stepping up and we will get through this
together at SBA we know that every phone
call email or application submitted has
a small business owner their employees
and the communities they support are on
the other side our most important
objective is to allow small businesses
to keep their employees on board and
keep their businesses viable through
this unprecedented disruption I want to
reiterate the importance of patience in
this process as we work together to
ensure that businesses are able to
access needed credit we will continue
working around the clock as we've done
with our federal and private sector
partners expanding capacity and working
to make our systems as robust as
possible to meet the needs Thank You mr.
president
oh no not minuchin Thank You mr.
president Thank You mr. vice president
Thank You Jovita
mr. president you've made clear to us we
now need to execute we need to get money
to small business and American workers
and that's what we're doing the SBA and
Treasury committed to get this program
up and running tomorrow and when Jovita
says people working around the clock
they literally we had both teams working
til four o'clock in the morning and
start working again today we've heard
feedback from lenders community banks
regional banks and we spent the last 24
hours making this system even easier so
this will be up and running tomorrow
I encourage all small businesses that
have 500 or fewer people please contact
your lenders and the FDIC and
we'll be able to do this any credit
union existing SBA lenders and FinTech
lenders you get the money you'll get it
the same day you use this to pay your
workers please bring your workers back
to work if you let them go you have
eight weeks plus overhead this is a very
important program I'm pleased to
announce we are going to raise the
interest rate on these loans and again
the interest rate is paid for as part of
the program the bar doesn't have to pay
this to 1% we had announced it was going
to be 50 basis points we've heard from
some smaller community banks that their
deposit costs even though the
government's borrowing at three or four
basis points this is on average a 90-day
loan to make this attractive for
community banks we've agreed to raise
the interest rate again I encourage
everybody take out the Paycheck
protection program I'm also pleased to
report the economic impact payments I
had previously said this would take us
three weeks I'm pleased to report that
within two weeks the first payments will
be direct deposit we'll remember it's
been a week already account and as the
president said last night the president
authorized me to say that anybody that
has Social Security recipients won't
need to file a new tax return and we'll
have that if we don't have your direct
deposit information we'll be putting up
a web portal so that you can put that up
it is a very large priority the
president has made clear we want to get
this money quickly into your hands I'm
also pleased to report that we continue
to work closely with the Federal Reserve
we're in the process of designing a new
facility that we call the Main Street
lending facility we're also looking at
facilities for state governments as well
and I'm also pleased to report the
employee retention credit it's up and
running the first $10,000 of wages you
get a 50% credit that's $5,000 per
person and for everyone who's kept
someone you can immediately get that
money you can deduct it from what you
owe the IRS immediately if you don't owe
us money you'll get a refundable tax
credit so that is up and running I'm
also pleased to report like that have
the pro
Grahame up and running we're taking
applications from the airlines from the
cargo companies and from national
security companies so thank you very
much mr. president mr. secretary a Chase
Bank sent a letter to its business
clients today saying that they don't
have necessary guidance from the SBA
from the Treasury Department be able to
accept
loan applications starting tomorrow the
need is clearly enormous but at least
one major bank says they're not fully
empowered yet to be able to help there I
spoke to all the CEOs yesterday I had a
conference call with them we got very
good input from them on what they needed
as I said people were working till four
o'clock I believe we just put up the
Federal Register with the new guidelines
for lenders I've been assured that the
banks will be in the process starting
tomorrow now again it's going to take a
little bit of time but we committed that
this will be available tomorrow and I
encourage all companies go to s be a
calm go to Treasury gov you can see the
information you need immediately and
that there's a tremendous power struggle
going on between the Treasury and SBA
and that it's over processing forms is
what they tell me that lenders are
actually opting out because they can't
make enough money to even service the
loans so how are you going to make sure
these small business owners get the
capital they need to survive right good
question first of all I can assure you
Jovita is here Jovita used to work for
me as the treasurer there's no power
struggle Jovita and our team as I said
worked together till four o'clock in the
morning started working at 7 o'clock
again we've made the forum simpler and I
can assure you at five points
I've told these bankers they should take
all their traders and put them in the
branches so they'll never be another
opportunity to earn five points on a 90
day government fully government
guaranteed loan this checks right into
direct deposit IRS
say take four to five months you're
saying two weeks let me be clear I don't
know let me be clear I don't know where
you're hearing these things I told you
this would be three weeks I'm now
committing to two weeks one week later
he says it's to it so we've got two
weeks to go from the three weeks right
the first money won't be in people's
will go up pretty quickly the question
is then folks who don't have direct
deposit and there was a statute well
there were released by the House Ways
and Means Committee today saying that
that process could take up to five weeks
that takes you to mid-august is that how
long that is not again let me just say
an Obama sent out these checks it took
months and months and months I am
assuring the American public they need
the money now what we're gonna do is
again if we have your information you'll
get it into in within two weeks Social
Security you'll get it very quickly
after that if we don't have your
information you'll have a simple web
portal you'll upload it if we don't have
that we'll send your checks in the mail
again we can process a lot of checks but
we don't want to send checks in this
environment we don't want people to get
checks we want to put money directly
into their account secretary this is for
I guess both you and the administrator
there been some anecdotal reports that
business people trying to get access to
the online site to submit the
applications the websites been crashing
I've heard of webinars going offline
because there's just too many people on
them so how do you guys gonna be ready
you know tomorrow to get these loans out
we've brought in a lot of external
resources at SBA and I understand
they're gonna be ready tomorrow for you
to fill out a form he's not saying
they're getting loans out tomorrow he's
saying at some point we'll be able to do
it same day it's gonna be up and running
now let me just be clear that doesn't
mean everybody is gonna get their loan
tomorrow like I said the system will be
up and running we encourage people over
the next week sign up you can go on
right now you can go on the web see what
information you need very simple process
subject have you've been in touch with
leader McConnell and Speaker Pelosi
about their differences right now about
another stimulus package I spoke Thai
spoken to the leader I spoken to the
speaker the I've spoken to the president
constantly when the president is ready
and thinks we should do the next stage
we're ready the president's talked about
the issue of infrastructure since the
campaign I think you know that's a big
priority for him and again if we run out
of money on the small business program
we'll be back right away to Congress to
get this increased the unemployment
numbers today
well let me just say you know we're
going through something that we've never
done before where the government has
shut down big parts of the economy
because of health reasons our economy
was in great shape our companies were in
great shape there are three ways that
Americans are going to be protected for
small business they'll get paid by their
business through this program the direct
deposit there's also enhanced
unemployment so we realized
unfortunately there are a lot of
companies that because they aren't in
business over a short period of time
again we're working with the states on
enhanced unemployment and as soon as the
medical professionals and the president
give the all-clear we're gonna have a
ton of liquidity we have about six
trillion dollars this has never been
done between us and the Fed to put into
the economy to support American workers
in American business in addition to the
jobless numbers we saw today these three
was signed before the social distancing
guidelines were extended for another
month
so what additional relief are you gonna
give to Americans as they stay out of
work for all these extra weeks and what
are you waiting for well we in designing
this program we thought that we had
liquidity for about ten weeks and and
that's what we've designed and again I
think the president's been very clear if
we need to go back to Congress to
support the American economy and
American workers we will be doing that
mr. secretary secretary ocean Hospital
Nancy Pelosi has form a select committee
to oversee the distribution of recovery
funds and she says she wants to make
sure that those funds are wisely and
efficiently spent do you think that's
what committee is something that's
necessary I I don't I mean you know the
both both parties wanted us to have
oversight wanted us to have transparency
we have full transparency we have a
Oversight Committee that the speaker
gets to pick someone the leader gets to
pick someone I believe there's five
people on it and again that that
committee will review the money that
we're spending and again we support full
transparency taxpayers should understand
how we're going to support this economy
and jobs secretary ii senator Murkowski
has asked you to consider providing
loans to energy companies under the
carrots act the phase three bill what
are your thoughts on that would you
consider providing those loans to energy
companies so thank you and let me
clarify I have very limited ability to
do direct loans out of the Treasury I
can do them for passenger airlines cargo
airlines contractors and national
security company how convenient
outside of that we work with the Federal
Reserve to create broad-based lending
facilities which we will do so our
expectation is the energy companies like
all our other companies will be able to
participate in broad-based facilities
whether it's the corporate facility or
whether it's the Main Street facility
but not direct lending out of the
Treasury those who don't have bank
accounts who don't have direct deposit
information on file with the IRS how
long would they have to wait for their
tax from today well for people who don't
have direct deposit again we'll have an
easy way they put it up we can on a
rolling basis I think you know within a
couple of days when they give it to us
we'll send the money out we do realized
there are people who are under banked
and again we're working with all the
digital companies prepaid debit cards
we're working with all of them to make
sure we have a process that every
American gets their money quickly this
money does people no good if it shows up
in four months and we will deliver on
that promise leave as a matter of weeks
then perhaps not months quickly as a
matter of weeks and not months that's
correct
area where you can make direct loans is
to the airlines how much do you expect
that the Treasury Department in the
federal government will be involved in
overseeing the operations of Airlines as
it pertains to which routes get cut back
how much they operate when people do
about their employees in the light so
there there are very strict requirements
that's built into the bill again this
was a bipartisan requirement one
anything we do with the airlines they
have to maintain substantially all of
their employees so again any money that
we provide them will go to pay their
employees we're gonna be working with
the Secretary of Transportation there
are requirements to maintain certain
routes so again we have a very clear
process we've hired three outside
advisors will be financial advisors and
three law firms will be releasing that
information shortly and I want to thank
them they're all working for basically
very very little money they couldn't
work for free so they've agreed to
basically work for what they would sign
up to work for charitable organizations
so again no big fees to bankers we got a
great team of three lawyers and three
financial advisors that will assist us
those people who are advising you when
you release the information of course we
will give you the names as well as the
the contracts so again right now so
again I'm happy to announce it
we have PG at the pjt partners okay is
going to do the passenger Airlines
Mullis and company is gonna do the cargo
and contractors and perilla wine
there is a hell of a lot of money being
made on this virus right now we'll
announce shortly that will be working in
each one of those sectors and again let
me just be clear we need to get this
done quickly the airlines need money
we're gonna work very closely with the
Department of Transportation and get
this done quickly we've actually already
received contracts from a lot of the
people again there's guidance up on the
web
full transparency we've asked for
applications on the airline issue again
speaker Pelosi and others have said that
the government taking stakes in those
airlines should not be a condition for
the federal government to provide
payroll support specifically what's your
response to that I spoke to the speaker
last night about that this was something
that was highly negotiated between the
Republicans and the Democrats the
president was personally involved in
this he was on the phone with us many
times Mitch McConnell mark how annoyed
Trump is getting that it's just minuchin
talking there is a specific line in the
bill that says that the secretary
meaning me will determine proper
compensation so this is not a bailout
for the airlines
and I will be working once we get our
advice from our financial advisors we
get the applications from the airlines
I'll be working very closely with the
president and we'll make sure that we
strike the right balance not a bailout
taxpayers get compensated but the these
airlines these are national security
issues we want to keep our Airlines in
tack
more broadly for perhaps for the
administrator is not for you as well
some small businesses restaurant orders
owners for example are finding that
laying off their employees so that they
can start collecting unemployment it's
better both for them as business owners
and for their workers what incentives do
they have right now to keep their
employees on the payroll if no one's
coming into their restaurant
well the incentive that you have and we
want American business to be kept intact
the incentive is these are loans that
turn into grants so if you're a business
owner and you're a restaurant you can
hire your people back you get money for
their their medical you keep them on the
medical plan you get money for your rent
you get money for your electricity so
you're motivated we want you to have a
business that you can reopen quickly
when it's appropriate so this doesn't
cost the business owners anything you
know when people talk about I can't
imagine any American worker who had a
job is offered to keep their job it
isn't gonna want to have it and let me
just be clear we've also talked about
this unemployment issue you can only get
unemployment if you don't have a job so
unemployment is intended for those
people that are some of the midsize or
larger businesses and we're very
sympathetic to this that these companies
can't afford and for those people the
enhanced unemployment will be a
significant benefit but not really 1/3
the class out of the American workforce
is small businesses under five hundred
people the president the vice president
the administrator and I want to make
sure this part of the economy is ready
and intact when we're ready to reopen
okay is there a certain category of
small businesses that you're most
concerned about restaurants from
swivelling weirdly about its waste it's
a great question we're concerned about
every small business there's 30 million
small businesses that were really
focused on and we're working feverishly
to make sure that we can provide the
available funds to them as quickly as
possible so it's 30 million small
businesses and the other businesses are
being dealt with with the PPP but the
Paycheck Protection there was also the
disaster what we call it the injury or
economic injury disaster loan and then
there was an advance associated with
that particular program as well so to
answer your question we're concerned
about all businesses and as the
secretary indicated we're looking at
employees being ready not lost in this
process where what we want businesses to
stay intact because they represent half
the half the GDP so if we spend a
trillion to support 10 trillion or 11
trillion I think that's a significant
investment and that's what we're focused
on I just wanna make one comment for
explanation because I want to make sure
everybody out there understands this if
you're an independent contractor if
you're a sole proprietor you're eligible
for this as well now that program won't
be up and running until next week but
again this is a very broad definition of
small business so if you're an
independent plumber if you're an
independent contractor you're covered
under this program slightly more
complicated you have to come in to your
bank and give them more information but
starting next week that part of the
program will be up and running also
charities charities as well very
important the vice president and
president makes sure that we covered
small charities in this
just not progress it does although there
are some technical issues but yes it
does include faith organizations this is
under the PPP yes the new SBA program
the Small Business Administration is
gonna give cash to churches mm-hmm thank
you okay so that begins right away and
they start handing out checks a lot of
people are gonna have their businesses
built back up quickly I hope and we'll
see complicated big small business is
actually big business
so I thank them both oh boy and please
we have some great gentlemen let me say
gentlemen
that's correct thank you very much today
my administration is also issuing new
guidelines to protect elderly Americans
who remain the most vulnerable by now
nursing homes should have suspended the
entry of all medically unnecessary
personnel today we're further
recommending that all nursing home
facilities decide the same staff to care
for the same group of residents
consistently to minimize any potential
spread and we're also urging facilities
to designate separate areas for healthy
and sick residents and this is a
practice that we probably will be
recommending into the future long after
the enemy is gone this particular enemy
is God we're also making every effort to
provide relief to our great veterans we
take very good care of our veterans at
my direction secretary Wilkie will use
any authority at his disposal to extend
deadlines for benefits and to postpone
debt collections we're now conducting
well over 100,000 corona virus tests per
day it's over a hundred thousand tests a
day and these are accurate tests and
they will rapidly which is more than any
other country in the world both in terms
of the raw number and also on a per
capita basis the most the FDA is also
authorized
first coronavirus antibody test
developed about selects a key step that
will help identify people who have
recovered and to understand their immune
response and their immune system
moments ago I directed secretary a czar
an Acting Secretary wolf to use any and
all available authority under the
defense production act to ensure that
domestic manufacturers have the supplies
they need to produce ventilators for
patients with severe cases of CO VI D 19
you know what that is right
become a very famous term Co VI D kovat
at some point actions every every one
General Electric Hill ROM Medtronic
ResMed Royal Philips and by air medical
overcome obstacles in the supply chain
that threatened the rapid production of
ventilators we have over a hundred
thousand being built right now or soon
to be started we anticipate issuing more
orders under the defense production act
in the very near future in addition to
the one that I've just signed against 3m
for face masks we assigned a element of
the act against element 3m and hopefully
they'll be able to do what they are
supposed to do just spoke to Mary Berra
of General Motors and she said they're
very soon going to be ready to start
production of the ventilators I have a
lot of ventilators that they've
committed to built and they'll be
starting very very quickly FEMA
continues to deliver resources to areas
most affected by the virus including New
York on top of the 3,000 beds were
already providing to the Javits Center
the Department of Defense is adding
another 48 ICU beds Governor Cuomo has
asked that this facility go and it's a
big beautiful facility it be converted
to a kovat hospital and we hadn't done
that yet we hadn't thought in terms of
doing that but there
uses their real demand is for that and
we had meetings on it with the task
force we had meetings with the military
and I've decided to say yes I'm going to
do that that I will be signing and
agreeing to a yes answer so that we will
be doing that and also we will be
staffing it so the federal government is
doing a lot of things that wasn't
anticipated that it do this is a 2500
and or 2900 can easily be set up
hospital built in Javits Center and so
we're going to be converting that to a
covet CoBank teen hospital and it's
going to be staffed by the military and
by the federal government and based on
the fact that I agreed to that we had
two other facilities that were likewise
asking for it and that would be in
Louisiana and also in Dallas and we'll
be doing those we spoke to the governor
of Louisiana spoke to the governor of
Texas and we've told them that we will
be staffing those hospitals again above
and beyond but that's okay we have to do
that in addition the u.s. NS comfort is
docked in New York to accept patients
that is a non Kovac to date FEMA has
delivered more than 4 million n95 mask
respirators and it's think of that 4
million 4 million don't forget we're a
secondary source the states are doing it
and we're backing them up but we've
gotten four million n95 respirators 1.8
million surgical masks 460 thousand face
shields 1.4 million gloves and four
thousand four hundred ventilators just
to the city and to the state of New York
and some of them now are being sent I
spoke with both Governor Cuomo and mayor
de Blasio a little while ago and some of
them are being sent to the city all of
America stands with the people of New
York in this time of need it's
definitely a hot spot but we have other
hot spots also and we're taking them
taking care of them very very strongly
very powerfully we have the finest
people in the world in those locations
and I think I just got bingo not only
acted early but acted quickly
professionally there's no people like
this doctors nurses first responders and
other health care providers who want to
help New York at this critical time
should visit website nyc.gov slash help
now nyc.gov slash help now they need
help now they need people to help them
we have great facilities and we've built
some brand new facilities big ones but
we need help we need help for
professional people so if you're in an
area that isn't so affected and you're a
doctor a nurse a healthcare worker
please get to that website and we would
really appreciate your help New York
City needs it Louisiana by the way needs
it Michigan needs it whatever you can do
those are very strong hotspots they need
help in recent weeks as the virus has
spread and economic hardship has
followed we have seen Americans unite
with incredible selflessness and
compassion I want to remind everyone
here in our nation's capitol especially
in Congress that this is not the time
for politics endless partisan
investigations you can tell he really
means that right I've already done
extraordinary damage to our country in
recent years you see what happens it's
witch hunt after witch hunt after witch
hunt and in the end the people doing the
witch hunt have been losing and they've
been losing by a lot and it's not any
time for witch hunts it's time to get
this enemy defeated conducting these
partisan investigations in the middle of
a pandemic is a really big waste of
vital resources time attention and we
want to fight for American lives not
waste
and build up my poll numbers because
that's all they're doing because
everyone knows it's ridiculous so we
want to focus on the people of this
country even the people of the world
we're gonna be able to help them because
right now is an example we're building
so many ventilators very very hard to
build but we're building thousands
thousands of them and a lot of them will
be coming at a time where we won't need
them as badly because it takes time very
complex very expensive and we'll be able
to help outside of our country we think
we'll be able to help that's something
that you cannot even understand
ventilators are being rationed in the
United States right now he's talking
about sending them somewhere else see an
affection there's no earthly force more
powerful than the patriotic bride that
stirs in our hearts and that is so true
it's incredible the job that everybody's
been doing everybody they don't sleep
they don't go to bed sometimes they get
nothing said to somebody recently on the
task force how many hours sleep have you
gotten over the last couple of days the
answer was none none in one
Massachusetts neighborhood citizens come
out of their homes each night at eight
o'clock from their porches and they sing
god bless america
others have joined in spreading from
house to house down one Street up to the
next until their little town with a
spirit of patriotism and reminding all
Americans that were all in this together
we'll fight together and we will win
together we're gonna wonder how that is
now what I'd like to do is I'm going to
step out we have a meeting on the
subject and I'm gonna step out just for
a few moments I'll be right back we'll
answer some questions why would you have
some very hardworking people who have a
few moments led by Vice President Mike
Pence
head of the task force and then Jared
Kushner is going to say a few are you
kidding me pull of check
Peter Navarro question marks and myself
I'll be right back so I'll see you in a
little while I did take a test it just
came out this is from the White House
physician you may have it just came out
I just took it this morning and I took
it it took me literally a minute
to take it and it took me I guess it was
14 or 15 minutes I went to work I didn't
wait for it but said it took 14 minutes
or something to come up with the
conclusion and it said the president
tested negative for kovat 19 so that's
the second one I think I took it really
out of curiosity to see how quickly it
worked and fast at work and it's a lot
easier I've done them both and the
second one is much more pleasant Jeff I
can tell you that much more pleasant so
I'll be back in a little while and Mike
please think over what a weird pressing
on pretty much she'll be right back
I'll be right back from the White House
coronavirus task force met today but
earlier in the day the president
convened all the key elements of our
supply chain team elements in the Oval
Office for an update on the progress
that we've been making working literally
around the clock to make sure that our
health care workers the people on the
frontlines have the personal protective
equipment and also the ventilators to be
able to meet this moment and today
you're going to hear from the people
that are literally working working each
and every day to make that happen dr.
deborah birx is also with us - she'll
reflect in a few moments on the progress
that that we're making analyzing the
data each and every day we're looking
county by county state by state
consulting with with governors and local
health officials at the present moment
more than 1.3 million tests have been
performed and as you all are aware some
236 thousand Americans have tested
positive for the corona virus with now
the losses over 5,000 Americans and our
hearts are with their families beyond
that we have been focusing not just on
ensuring the testing is occurring but
that the supplies are flowing as the
president just announced he made a
decision today to deploy thousands of
n95 mass directly to New York City's
public hospitals and our team will speak
that in just a moment and also the
president took the unprecedented step to
direct the Department of Defense to use
military health care personnel to
operate all Kovan facilities at the
Javits Center in New York at the
Convention Center in New Orleans and at
the Convention Center in Dallas and
we've informed each of the governors of
those states today that their requests
we were making those military medical
personnel available to operate in all
kovat facility but we would emphasize to
people in that community who believe
you've been impacted or if contracted
the corona virus contact your local
health care provider we anticipate in
the New York area that your local
healthcare provider will make the
decision whether you are transferred to
the Javits Center and in all cases
simply look to the guidance of your
local governor's about how best to
receive the care that every American
every American is entitled to have
beyond that let me say that we have been
working through FEMA's acquisition
process not only to deploy but to to
gather up personal protective equipment
and in just a few moments you will hear
from Admiral John Paul of check about
the extraordinary progress that we have
made in deploying not just the strategic
national stockpile but also in
identifying on the commercial
marketplace around America and around
the world literally millions of n95
masks surgical gowns gloves protective
equipment and at this point we've
distributed some 7600 ventilators and
you'll hear today specifically about the
states that have received those
ventilators we're just this team is
truly acted in an inspiring way and
literally is is working with dozens and
dozens of people at the at the FEMA
stabilization task force to make sure
that we are leaving no stone unturned to
find the supplies we need let me also
say today you're going to hear from
Jared Kushner great senior advisor
the President of the United States is
that someone that the White House or the
virus task force directed to work with
FEMA on supply chain issues and in
recent weeks he's been leading a working
group in conjunction with FEMA that
literally has identified millions of
medical supplies around the nation can
you Amanda round-the-world and we're
grateful for his efforts and his
leadership finally you'll hear from
Peter Navarro who will explain the
action the president took today using
the defense production act horrible as
you hear details today about medical
supplies that have been distributed
those that have been purchased those
that were making available ventilators
distributed to hospitals and those that
are available let me just remind every
American that you can make a difference
in ensuring that every patient has the
treatment that they deserve every
healthcare provider every doctor and
nurse and nurses assistant has the
protective gear to provide the care that
you would want your family to have by
putting into practice the president's 30
days to slow the spread I mean we we
want you to take to heart the
president's coronavirus guidelines for
America first to protect your own health
to protect the health of your family to
protect the health of your community we
know so many people are asymptomatic and
people that literally don't know they
have the corona virus but have the
ability to infect others we want you to
put these guidelines into practice
social distancing using a drive-through
at a restaurant washing your hands on a
regular basis but as we focus today on
supplies make no mistake about it every
American can make sure that our health
care workers and more importantly
Americans that are struggling with
coronavirus have the equipment to
support their treatment by putting these
principles into practice because the
fewer Americans that contract the corona
virus the fewer Americans will have to
enter our healthcare system and that
will continue to preserve the capacity
in our health care economy so we we
thank the millions of Americans who
responded in the first
days of 30 days to slow the spread and
I'm just absolutely confident than in
the days ahead every American's going to
do their part for your health your
family's health the health of your
community and to ensure the strength and
vitality of the greatest healthcare
system in the world with that let me
introduce a Jared Kushner obiga I work
that he's been doing really Adler to be
brave element to this uninsurance supply
chain to meet this moment Jared
Thank You mr. vice president and thank
you for your great leadership on the
task force task and thank you to dr.
Burks and dr. pathy as well it's been
honor working with you these past few
weeks when the Vice President first
asked me to help on the task force with
different tasks I asked the president
what he expected from the task force and
how I can best serve him and the task
force what the president asked is that
all of the recommendations that we make
be based on data he wanted us to be very
rigorous to make sure that we were
studying the data collecting data a lot
of things in this country we're
happening very quickly
and we want to make sure that we were
trying to keep updating our models and
making sure that we were making informed
decisions and informed recommendations
to him based on the data that we were
able to collect and put together the
president want to make sure that we had
the best people doing the best jobs and
make that service they had the right
people focused on all the things that
needed to happen to make sure that we
can deliver in these unusual times for
the American people
the president also instructed me to make
sure that I break down every barrier
needed to make sure that the teams can
succeed this is a an effort where the
government is doing things that the
government doesn't normally do where
we're stretching where we're we're
acting very quickly and the president
wants to make sure that the White House
is fully behind the different people
running the different lines of effort to
make sure that we get everything done in
a speed that the president demands the
president also wanted us to make sure we
think outside the box make sure we're
finding all the best thinkers in the
country making sure we're getting all
the best ideas and that we're doing
everything possible to make sure that we
can keep Americans safe and make sure we
bring a quick end to this and the best
way possible how was that real all the
different aspects that need to be
thought of while we do this
this truly is a historic challenge we
have not seen something like this in a
very very long time but I am very
confident that by bringing innovative
solutions to these hard problems we will
make progress today we are briefing the
president earlier he asked me to come
out and talk a little bit about what
we've been doing on the supply chain
Task Force which Admiral plug check has
been leading and and what he's been very
impressed by is the way that we've been
resourceful to find product all over the
world all over the country and we are
finding ways to solve the different
problems the president's been very very
hands-on in this he's really instructed
us to leave no stone unturned confused
what's going on this is the president's
son-in-law who is I guess now a major
player in fighting the invisible scourge
was running low on on critical supply he
instructed me this morning I called dr.
Katz who runs the system asked him which
supply was the most supply he was
nervous about he told me was the n95
masks i asked what his daily burn was
and i basically got that number called
ab Admiral of check made sure we had the
inventory we went to the president today
and earlier today the president called
mayor de Blasio to inform him that we
were going to send a month of supply to
the New York public hospital system to
make sure that the workers on the front
line can rest assure that they have the
n95 masks that they need to get through
the next month we'll be doing similar
things with all the different public
hospitals that are in the hotspot zones
and making sure that we're constantly in
communications with the local
communities one thing I will say just
based on data is that we've been getting
a lot of data from different governors
and from different mayor's and from
different cities one thing I've seen
FEMA do very very well over the last
week or so is now we're getting
real-time data from a lot of cities
people who have requests for different
products and supplies a lot of them are
doing it based on projections which are
not the realistic projected projections
the projections change everyday as we
see the cases as we see the impacts of
the stops of spread effort that this
task force recommended and the president
has been pushing forward so I do think
that we'll see that hopefully there'll
be impact of that and the task force has
been working very hard through the FEMA
group with Admiral Apple of check to
make sure that we're getting the
supplies to people
before they run out and making sure that
we're doing it in a proper way I'd like
to just introduce Admiral of check who
before coming to this I guess still is
he's the vice director for logistics for
the Joint Staff I got a call from one of
the senators saying well why don't you
put a great military person in charge of
the logistics in the supply chain and
the defense production act and I said
well the president already did that this
is the best man that we have in the
country for supplies and logistics I
joined the task force 13 days ago over
at FEMA and he's built a team really at
the direction of the vice president that
includes people from FEMA OMB the FDA
HHS the White House and from everywhere
else and what they've done over the last
13 days has been really extraordinary
we've done things that the government
has never done before quicker than
they've ever done it before and what
we're seeing now is we found a lot of
supplies in the country
we've been distributing them where we
anticipate there will be needs and also
trying to make sure that we're hitting
places where there are needs so I can
tell you the people in the in the Task
Force they're working day and night
you've got a lot of people in the
government we recognize the challenge
that America faces right now we we know
what a lot of the people on the
frontlines are facing the fear that they
have that they won't have the supplies
they need and our goal is to work as
hard as we can to make sure that we
don't let them down so I just want to
thank everybody and with that I'll
introduce Admiral flood check who's
doing an amazing job Jared Kushner's
presence here is really sinister in some
weird way mr. Kirschner mr. president so
today I'm gonna cover a couple items a
couple of five things first thing I want
to talk about is resources pushed out
from the federal government and then I'm
gonna talk about there's this air bridge
which you may have heard about I'm gonna
talk about data as you said we're mister
Kushner is absolutely right we're trying
to be data-driven and then I'm gonna
talk a little bit about how we're trying
to expand the dust robles year to meet
this challenge so the the first thing I
want to talk about is surgical masks so
we've all
quickly stated numbers here so these I'm
about to go through several different
slides to give you just scale and
magnitude of federal resources that have
been applied at the problem so 27 point
1 million surgical masks pushed out to
state state governments for and ninety
five minutes nineteen point five million
and ninety-five masks and so if I was if
I was in a local hospital that was
running short
I would I would look upward because the
federal government has pushed out
resources so for protective gloves
twenty two point four million twenty two
point four point four million pairs of
protective gloves for face shields 5.2
million face shields for ventilators we
have pushed to to the states more than
seven thousand six hundred ventilators
and I think as I was coming over here
that numbers changed slightly I think
it's now seven thousand six hundred and
forty given to these states to the
parameter of these states so it we
wanted you to have some numbers now as
we've indicated we have ventilators in
the national stockpile we pushed
ventilators out we're holding
ventilators to put to the point to need
but we're also buying values asking the
industrial base who produces
approximately prior to Kovac
approximately thirty thousand
ventilators a year we are going to over
the next several months by the end of
June work to acquire a hundred thousand
and so one of the one of the tools that
we're gonna I can anticipate needing
we've already executed is all of those
vendors that we're buying them from will
need potentially will need help in their
supply chains with their suppliers we
might rate orders we might help them get
ahead of others in that endeavor so I
think mr. Navarro is gonna talk a little
bit more of that later so let me talk
about the air bridge so it not normally
takes approximately thirty seven days to
get from overseas your product load it
get into the United States and
distribute it that's about thirty seven
days so to prime the pump so to speak we
have lined on an air bridge to get
product here faster working with our
major suppliers as they have as they
work to fill orders to get more to
health care workers now we are working
to align transportation to product and
one of the things we're also doing is
the team that works for me or scouring
the globe in finding pockets of personal
protective equipment that might not
otherwise be in the US hospital supply
chain that is also going on these
flights six completed and a number
scheduled twenty eight twenty eight
flights scheduled here in the near
future we are working towards some days
we'll have one flight some days that
might be two flights multiple flights
over the next coming days these twenty
eight or as far as I can see out a
couple of weeks then again matching
product to flights to create volume in
the supply chain here faster than the
thirty seven days
I'm just gonna leave that up as I talk
about a few other items so let's talk
about New York City and the public
health hospitals I believe it's there
called New York City Health and
Hospitals president directed as I speak
there are pallets being formed truck
being loaded I gave a an address in New
York City here an hour or two ago and
one of our distributors is making that
happen and that delivery will happen
tomorrow on a data front this is almost
unprecedent this is a commercial supply
chain with six to seven major
distributors of health equipment we
brought them all in and we said we we
need to make informed decisions and we
are gonna help make informed allocation
decisions so within a matter of days
feeding from their business systems
their enterprise resource like systems I
brought on board a tool a supply chain
tower that the DoD was using to manage a
supply chain for a very complex weapon
system their data goes into a Donnelly
we have a tool to be able to use their
data and see it I can tell what product
is coming in what their orders are what
they're filling what they're not filling
and see the volume in the supply chain
and understand what they're doing down
to the county level we're working to get
it potentially down to the hospital
level so this two hundred and some-odd
n95 respirators we took a look in there
in the in the supply chain we said we we
can't we have the volume to go do that I
called the distributor and they're
making they're making
happy we anticipate as the hot spots
around the country we anticipate these
vendors at our direction helping them
allocate product to the right place at
the right time this is all a little
weird so if I talk finally about
expanding the industrial base
so the vice-president who is that
Walmart the other day we told them I
want to get in this game how do I do
that
so I got the call we provided them
specifications and a Walmart is gonna
have use their suppliers to cut fabric
make gowns so product but that's not
always the case we have lots of folks
that want to help believe you will see
in the coming days the use of the
defense production act in creative ways
to help people that are not doing this
today to do it we have essentially leads
with the number yesterday was 210
believers but probably grew today that
we are working with to find how each one
of those might need help to get in the
game that's not in the game to increase
the throughput through the through the
healthcare market again the president
gave me one task get more to our health
care workers now I would wrap and I took
that to heart because I have not that I
don't need that from the president that
that direction to move out but I I have
family in New York my sister's a nurse
practitioner in a Westchester hospital
and my niece is a nurse on a Long Island
Hospital and I have other health care
professionals in the family so I have
skin in this game
the president asked me to get more of
the health care workers we got to get
more to health care workers the 200,000
is going out it'll be it'll be delivered
tomorrow what what Jared announced what
the Admiral just unpacked is that
pallets are being loaded right now to
send 200,000 in 95 hours mass to New
York City good clarification health no
one needs what was being set it was a
public health warehouse in New York City
all the health care workers helped us on
the way on the tools and the data you
have available to you where is the log
jam where has it been have you
identified that because that's gonna pay
all this we have millions more PPE is
going out the door as you all know the
frontline unnumbered you get you
everything you this way we put up a lot
of numbers iock said that if you're not
a you're in a hospital and you're not
seeing PPE I would look up to the state
level first they're blaming the
and the reason for that is because
according to governor's and also I don't
think this guy's really prepared for
we're getting hammered
where's up there about what is going to
the private sector can you tell us what
percentage of the supplies on these
large cargo planes are going to private
companies versus FEMA versus the state
mission percent so this product that
we're moving is primarily commercial
product that would enter the commercial
system and be distributed through
financial business transactions between
hospitals and these distributors to
clarify that that explains why states
say they're bidding like they're on eBay
because the supplies are going to the
private sector hence is gonna have to
say we need Navarro to speak he's gonna
have to pull them how things that's not
only how things work right so I'm not
here to disrupt a a supply chain say
look these these six distributors six
seven they have six to seven hundred
warehouses they have trucks to go to the
hospital door every day we're bringing
product in they're filling orders for
hospitals nursing homes like normal I'm
putting volume into that system I would
say that that we have the data now last
so we put together this data element
over the last you know what thirteen
days who's feeling confident get the
people in look at the problem build this
I am now seeing truth about what's in
the supply chain and I would say that
there's been some abnormal behavior okay
House Oversight Committee Democrats say
the FEMA officials told them that the
ventilator is the government is ordered
won't be
June which is well after the expected
peak will the defense production Act
memo signed today do anything to speed
that up
yes sir will mr. vara we'll talk about
that we're online to receive several
thousand ventilators in the month of
April and several thousand more
ventilators in the month of May
ramping up to a big number in June again
going from you know an industry that
produced from back with a piece of paper
30 annual 30,000 we marry up we're
marrying up we're CDC where the demand
for kovat is - what's in this commercial
system we're providing that to these to
the commercial system and we are making
allocations to those most pressing need
13 days we now have the data we now can
make informed decisions and so all of
the I need I need I need I now know the
volume that has been happening and needs
to be happy
they're waiting on us as well you talk
about though you alluded to the fact
there is possibly some shady business
going on that the product is here in the
United States and coming here yes and it
is coming here it's coming from China
it's in more warehouses it's being made
here in the United States that's in
warehouses but it's going to the highest
bidder
so what can be done to keep those
products here in the United States not
go overseas where companies are making a
lot of money and and yeah levels you can
even go to good right here in the US I
would love to hear it being done because
doctors are great questions I mean yeah
let me give you the the bigger view of
the DPA will directly address that what
we have essentially is a nation at war
we have a wartime president standing
behind me the defense production act is
one of the most powerful weapons this
administration can use weapons like
laudable enemy of the virus when I spoke
with you last week I explained the three
points of the compass DPA can be used to
hit the the first one is mobilization of
the industrial base this can involve
things like repurposing from say a
distiller like Pernod Ricard
from liquor to hand sanitiser it can
also involve expansion of production
which is having Honeywell which makes
n95 masks open a new factory in
smithfield rhode island with respect to
the second point of the compass
allocation of resources we have two
issues there if you look at the
manufacturer itself you what you want to
make sure is that the supply chain which
can go seven tiers deep has enough
components in that supply chain so we
can actually make what we need and then
once it's made you also want to make
sure that it goes to the right right
people and then the third point of the
compass which which addresses what
you're talking about
is is basically bust them I call it
hoarding of critical or threatened
materials so let me walk through what
what the president did today in terms of
wrong action what we've done the DPA
across those three points the first
order
president Trump sign was was vigorous
Swift it was the GM order which directed
GM to make ventilators in Kokomo Indiana
in Trump time which is to say as fast as
possible as the president mentioned he'd
spoke to Mary Barra
today the CEO of GM that is moving
forward at the same time as the Ford
project is moving forward in Ross and
Ville Michigan and I've issued a
challenge to those two companies out of
Ford versus Ferrari this is Ford versus
GM let's see who gets those ventilators
out first now the second point of the
compass which these two orders addressed
today is this allocation of resource
issues the ventilator companies
themselves express concern that in this
rush to build ventilators there would be
pressure on that supply chain so what
they they requested that we do and the
president do is to use the DPA to give
this gentleman here's one of the
strongest gentlemen in the world in
terms of applying things is to give him
the ability to prioritize that supply
chain for those Benevento later
manufacturers and he will do things like
give them what's called a do rating in
the defense procurement which will allow
them to get what they need now the
second order which the President signed
today has to do with the other part of
the equation which is once they make
this stuff okay where it does it go to
the right right folks and this is a
three M order and and I hope you guys
are realizing that this entire answer
could have been 60 seconds and have
communicated way more the the production
that 3m does around the world enough of
it is coming back here to the right
places so what's gonna happen with the
signing to that order and Trump time is
we're gonna resolve that issue with 3m
probably by tomorrow close of business
because we can't afford to lose days or
hours even minutes in this crisis math
now the third part of the compass the
third point there if this gets to the
horny
issue president stood up here with with
he's the commander in chief but we have
a sheriff in town too attorney general
bar
he stood up here with the Jena tourney
general bar and bill bar said I'm gonna
go out and bust him and guess what three
days ago
DOJ went into a warehouse in Jersey
grabbed PPE and the beauty of that the
beauty yeah we wasn't only seized but
within hours it was turned around and
given to health care professionals in
New York and New Jersey
that's a beautiful thing that's a
beautiful case of using the DPA now
what's going to happen tomorrow is
president's going to sign another order
which is in the works this is
interesting there is a black market
springing up which you have described
where we're having people bid against
each other brokers come in they're
bidding and bidding on all this
different PPE it's driving the price up
and guess what you know where it's going
the domestic sources here are being
exported
when President prop heard about daddy
said that's not going to happen on
anymore on in my watch so tomorrow
what's gonna do is it's going to empower
Customs and Border Protection with the
help of people like the post office and
Express Mail consigners might have to
close in June cuz they got no money from
stimulus what is this guy on so we are
going to crackdown unmercifully and I
would say to the the hoarders out there
the brokers are trying to make money off
of the misery of people in this country
around the world that's got to stop but
you've got inventory what you need to do
is pick up a phone and not call somebody
out in around the world you call FEMA
and say we got some stuff we'll give it
to you at a fair price and be done with
that because that stuff has absolutely
got to stop so that's that's what
hanging out you know so that's that's
what we're going to be looking for and
when we hear cases like this we're going
to aggressively issue order after order
to crack down on it now before this is
not my role to take a bunch of questions
but let me tell you one other thing
before I leave the podium
it's a story which I'd love to share
with you today
no again illustrates one of the key
principles of this president in this
vice-president which is this Wed add the
full force of the federal government
with the full power of private
enterprise and just two days ago we at
the White House got an urgent SOS from
the chief of police of the New York
Police Department and they are in a
situation now because of the strain on
their resources where personnel such as
their homicide detectives were offering
you go on into houses and deal with with
Cova issues without protective gear now
the beauty of this president is because
of his leadership we were able to solve
that problem in two phone calls to make
phone calls
the first one went to Phoebe novakovic
the General Dynamics Phoebe can you call
Tom Kennedy of Raytheon I need you guys
to basically scoop up all the tie back
suits you can you find any gloves you
can this president under his leadership
right and that voluntary efforts and the
pride and patriotism he talked about
earlier that we had 4,000 tie back suits
delivered in the New York PD within 16
hours that's that's a new record in
Trump time at the same time a second
phone call can't believe this is a
Boston guy what an embarrassment Bert in
Laurel Lane at UPS they were on the same
phone call he said Terrell or we got
this issue they need hand sanitizer
literally within two hours we had 50
gallon drums 6,000 gallons a hand
sanitizer on a UPS truck heading up to
the NYT PD and it probably arrived today
with a promise from pono that they will
continue to supply the NYPD throughout
the course of this crisis so this this
is a beautiful thing you know that
America is rallying to we are becoming a
stronger more united nation and I
couldn't be more proud of this president
this administration these guys up here
we're doing a heck of a job organizing
the supply chain and my promise to you
is that the president is going to use
that DPA to make sure
or that the American people really are
healthcare professionals get the PPE the
medicines everything we need so let me
let me stop there I don't think it's Lee
place here to to field a bunch of
questions Oh God
one of the one of the things that this
crisis has taught us or is that we are
dangerously over dependent on a global
supply chain for our medicines like
penicillin our medical supplies like
masks and our medical equipment like
ventilators we have right now as we
speak
over 50 countries have already imposed
some forms of export restrictions in
their country against the rest of the
world and what we've what we're learning
from that is that no matter how many
treaties you have no matter how many
alliances no matter how many phone calls
when push comes to shove you run the
risk as a nation of not having what you
need and if there's any vindication of
the president's by American secure
borders and a strong manufacturing base
philosophy strategy and belief that is
this crisis because it underscores
everything that we see there so the bite
American order which which is going
through process would do do couple
things it would simply say not during
this crisis because we don't want to
disrupt anything I want to be really
clear about that but going forward after
this is over the VA DoD HHS and this
government buys American for essential
medicines or medical countermeasures and
the medical supplies and equipment we
need at the same time it will deregulate
so we can get the FDA and EPA to
facilitate domestic manufacturing this
is painful guys and then innovate
because the key here the key here is
having
advanced manufacturing on US soil that
can leapfrog other countries so we don't
have to worry about competing against
cheap sweatshop labor relaxed
environmental regulations different tax
regimes and the massive subsidies of
foreign governments who are actually
directly attacking our industrial base
so be patient with that sir it's it the
other priorities we have right now or
the DPA and discussion would be Laos
course is doing but if we learn anything
from this crisis it should be never
again never again should we have to
depend on from rest of the world for our
essential medicines and countermeasures
and by the way we've cut them out also
to be honest we've stopped orders going
from certain places and in a couple of
places like we had a big order going to
Italy on the important outfits and some
ventilators and it was going to Italy
they made the order a long time ago and
I said you got to let it go they've had
an order and I could have cut it under
the Act I could have cut it I said nope
can't do that you got to let it go you
know they have big problems we had an
order going to Spain and I said let it
go I could have stopped it I said let it
go we're gonna be fine I said let it go
so it works that way also one other
thing that's to your question often
times and we've told this to the
governor's mic we've been very strong in
this have if you think there's bidding
between federal government and state let
us know and we'll drop out immediately
or you drop out we lower the price know
if we're bidding against each other I
said find out who it is and usually they
know everyone knows and we're notified
and we get notified and will either drop
out or they'll drop out but we have
another problem there 151 countries out
there beyond the states there are a
hundred and fifty-one countries that
have this problem and they're ordering
too
it's really a mess now in a little while
the hardest thing together the
ventilators because they're you know it
takes a while to build them and we have
a lot we have thousands of them being
built right now in a little while that
worth about five dollars but right now
they're very valuable and we're gonna
have a lot of them being shipped in fact
that's why General Motors called up
before Mary
that's why others called up two days ago
they called up that they're all in
production and they'll start they're
starting to arrive in a week and a half
but there'll be a time when we're gonna
build stockpiles by the way the states
should have been building their
stockpile we have almost 10,000 and our
stockpile and we've been building and
we've been supplying it but the states
should be building we're back up we're
not an ordering clerk we're back up and
we've done a number ordering job like
for instance who ever heard of a
governor calling up sir can you build us
a hospital three thousand five hundred
rooms and we built it can you build us
four medical centers we built it can you
deliver a ship the hospital ship with a
thousand rooms and we did it and we did
it in Los Angeles - we've been an
unbelievable job these people and so and
thousands of people behind them but
we're back up ideally those hospitals
would have had all this equipment
ideally those states should have had all
this equipment and I think they will the
next time you know you heard the case
where thousands of ventilators could
have been had at a very inexpensive
price three years ago and a certain
state decided not to exercise that right
because they wanted to build a road or
they wanted to build something else
because it's big money you're talking
about I think it was a billion dollars
but you're talking about a lot of money
for something that may never happen
because normally on a ventilator other
than a pandemic or an epidemic you
wouldn't you you wouldn't need anything
like this hospitals have three
ventilators big hospitals and they get
by with it and now they want thousands I
mean they want thousands of ventilators
you call up a governor and they'll say
sir could you go against and ventilate
somebody has ever heard of a thing like
this so they've done some job let me
just tell you when secretary minuchin
spoke they want you to call not calm but
sba.gov tells you at the time okay for
the application and for an ordination
later
so it's SBA Small Business sba.gov okay
if you don't mind yeah let's go please
Thank You mr. president I want to follow
up from a question yesterday regarding
her administration's denial the
expansion of Islamist care special
enrollment period in the wake of this
pandemic in your own words VP pence gave
a five-minute non answer but people
facing this pandemic illness and even
worse most experts say that having
health care is critical to our nation's
health and financial well-being good
question can you assure Americans
tonight that you will reopen Obama care
marketplace ability they can be covered
in this - he was well we're doing better
than that yeah no I understand the
question and we're doing better than
that we're going to try and get a cash
payment to the people and we're working
out the mechanics of that with
legislature so we are going to try and
get them a cash payment because just
opening it up doesn't help as much so
we're gonna work it out so we're going
to try and get for that certain group of
people it's a certain group of people a
cash payment
and just the question earlier about the
bidding what happens though when states
are bidding against each other on this
well they have that and they have to
work that out what they should do is
they should have loaned before this
pandemic arrived they should have been
on the open market just buying there was
no fool a petition you could have made a
great price the states have to stock up
it's like to like those things they
waited they didn't want to spend the
money because they thought this would
never happen and their shelves in some
cases were bare and by the way in some
cases they weren't they were beautifully
serviced they deserve but in some cases
their shelves were bare so the best
thing they can do is when times become
normalized and they will hopefully soon
the question essentially now when states
are bidding against each other because
so much is being done right now in terms
of protective gear protective outfits
a lots being done it's going to be
within six months it's going to be sold
for the right price they go to stack up
for the next time but we are doing that
and the admiral's done a fantastic job i
senator schumer wrote a letter today and
he says you should put a military
manager Jessica look if you knew a
little bit more we have one of the most
highly respected people in the military
the Admiral this is what he does to very
professionally and he's in charge but
Chuck didn't know that okay Jeff
tweeted this morning about your call
with the Saudi Arabians NBS we've had
some people say that the figures that
you cited between ten thousand ten
million and fifteen million barrels per
day it's not what they're agreeing to
can you be more specific about I don't
know what their great day life I think
they might agree to more than that look
Russia how you Nasser Russia yeah we did
say that actually Russia talked about
ten million barrels Russia and Saudi
Arabia are fighting over this and as
everybody knows it's you know really
killing an industry hurting Russia badly
hurting Saudi Arabia baby can go I said
this is an easy one it should be an easy
one and it may be ten and it may be more
than that I was actually told it may be
tend as I told somebody before it may be
ten and it may be more than that maybe
it's fifteen maybe it goes up to fifteen
could be as high as fifteen and you know
there's a tremendous oversupply right
now that industry was it was over
supplied before the virus and when the
virus came along they lost thirty five
forty percent of the world and there's
an unbelievable you can't get a ship
down every ship is loaded to the gills
sitting out someplace in the ocean
there's storage tanks they're not even
ships the storage tanks so it would be
great for Russia it would be great for
Saudi Arabia I hope they make that deal
but that's what they told me they said
they said it's they swell I think I
think it'll be hopefully soon I think
hopefully they'll announce something
soon now imagine dragging about raising
oil prices doesn't happen I guess in
which case there's another alternative
but I'd rather not see that other
alternative I hope they can make a deal
they both want I think they both want to
make a deal and they're both smart they
love their countries they want to make a
deal that's good but it's also good for
the world if they do because you save an
industry
go ahead go ahead in the back what do
you mean by cash payments I'm going to
let Mike because we went over this very
specifically it was no idea right Thank
You mr. president
as I said yesterday the president's put
a priority on ensuring that no American
has to worry about the cost of
coronavirus testing and we've been
working every day not answer to make
sure that Americans don't have to worry
about the cost of treatment and at this
point the White House coronavirus task
force is working on a proposal for the
president to use some of the 100 billion
dollars that we're making available to
hospitals to compensate the hospitals
directly for any coronavirus treatment
that they provide to uninsured Americans
we're working out the details of that
the president will make a final decision
tomorrow we expect an announcement but
the president's made it very clear we
don't want any American to worry about
the cost of getting a test okay that's
an answer at least there might be alive
but again and we've expanded coverage
through Medicaid we've expanded coverage
through Medicare health insurance
companies around the country including
Blue Cross and just today announced that
all of their members will be waiving all
co-payments on coronavirus treatment
before there's some 30 odd million
uninsured Americans the president has
directed the coronavirus task force who
find a way to make sure that they know
we will find a way to pay for your
coronavirus treatment and the president
will be addressing that and announcing
that tomorrow
appointment clarification and then a
follow-up question yesterday you said
that you spoke to Florida Governor
Rhonda Sanchez before he issued his stay
at home order did you advise him to
issue that order no but I talked to him
about it and he wants to do what's right
for the people of Florida he's been a
great governor you could see that just
by his popularity which is 6ly powerful
guns done a fantastic job and he made
the decision but we spoke before he made
this decision yes I also said that he is
considering clean people who were
suspected of having phone a virus or who
have tested positive for it in isolation
centers and the EP so yeah they
consulted but I haven't heard that was
rich Thank You mr. president
evany mountains from the new york post a
few hours ago Manta Blasio the mayor of
New York said that New York is leaving
their part should wear masks they also
might wear masks when they're with other
people are you considering that kind of
recommendation on a federal level and if
you are how would you prevent a request
well I think they're going to be coming
out with regulations on that and if
people want to abide by them frankly I
don't think you could I don't think
they'll be mandatory because some people
don't want to do that but if people want
it as an example in the mix if people
wanted to wear them they can if people
wanted to use scarves believe she's
Australian not really people have the
accent they can in many cases the scarf
is better it's thicker I mean you can if
you depending on the material that you
want but hey I can do that if they want
now a recommendations coming out we'll
see what that recommendation is but but
I will say this they can pretty much
decide for themselves right now
Nutan why not just first-class amenity
this is best for dr. Burks but we've
heard some differing guidance here at
the w-h-o I'm even the Surgeon General
have talked about various studies that
show that masks in addition to maybe not
even being helpful to protecting people
may actually increase the rates of
illness because people touch the masks
and they touch themselves you talked a
little bit about to the edge maybe I
will get worse and you might mention
that other point Joseph thank you so I
hope you got from the conference today
that we're triangulating data that we
know from the case numbers the testing
numbers the supply chain numbers to
create an integrated picture so that we
can really support hospitals in their
needs and I think that level of
granularity really critical secondly I
just want to make the point that we
really applaud the governor's that are
looking at a whole of state or a whole
of Metro approach and what do I mean by
that the United States going into this
had about a hundred and sixty thousand
ventilators across the United States and
another 60 to 70 thousand anesthesia
machines that's about five times what
most of the European countries have but
it's a matter of distribution to need
and I really applaud the governor's that
are bringing together their public
hospitals with their more private
hospitals and their visibility across
their state because what we tried to
talk about yesterday is every state
every county is different that's why
we're looking at it at that level of
granularity and as we move through this
epidemic the needs need to be very
tailored to those counties and frankly
those hospitals I mean there is a reason
why the President and mr. Kushner have
been very much involved in finding out
can you imagine why is that because the
public hospitals sometimes have the
weakest supply chain because they're
often sometimes not as attractive to
private sector distributors or they may
be too busy caring for the needs of
patients to be really on top of their
order
and their supply chains so really
listening to the community that's at the
front of this fight and getting feedback
from those specific communities no
matter where they are and listening to
the frontline health care workers
because it's their reality that is
important to all of us whether you're
the mayor or the governor or the federal
government and if they are saying they
need something you get let me just
introduce a question here so when she
says we have five times the ventilators
that European countries have is she
talking about compared to an individual
European country because if so we have
three hundred and forty million people
five times doesn't sound like a lot is
she saying all of Europe combined that
would be a weird thing like it's very
opaque what it is that she's even
asserting happens now you have to have
very good data in order to be willing to
work in that level of granularity and
that's what we've been working on to
really develop that level of granularity
to ensure that so I just wanted to say
one other thing about testing I'm just
to give you the bottom line data of what
we're seeing
we appreciate the groups who are
reporting not everyone is reporting yet
and this is part of us trying to
understand at a very granular level we
do have two states that do have 35%
positives and that's New York and New
Jersey so that confirms very clearly
that that's a very clear and important
hot song Louisiana though has 26% of
their tests are positive Michigan
Connecticut Indiana Georgia Illinois so
that should tell you where the next hot
spots are coming are at 15% has positive
and then Colorado DC Rhode Island and
Massachusetts are at 13%
there's a significant number of states
still under 10% every one that I didn't
discuss California and Washington
remains steady at an 8% rate so what
we're seeing finally is testing
improving more testing being done still
a high level of negatives in states
without hot spots allowing them to do
more of this surveillance and
and then prioritizing this new rapid
test kit to those areas that may not
have the same amount of access to the
Indian Health Services and to the public
health institutions and the public
Houston State labs so that they can use
that and start forward leaning into
surveillance now we know that our people
waiting for tests and they're waiting
for tests because when these areas
became very when they got onto the
logarithmic curve we prioritize people
whose decisions where the test decision
would make it critical for their care
and so we put prioritized hospitals and
we prioritize nurses and doctors and
frontline workers so that means if you
went through a drive-through or you went
through your doctor you could have that
to law that delay so the mass so what I
try to give you is how we're using data
in a very granular way and we're not
there is experiential data when you look
at communities that have often time
utilized mass in general for personal
protection from when they particularly
are themselves sick and have used their
masks in public and we've looked at the
rate of this Kovan 19 in those
populations and then we're looking at
the scientific evidence to bring those
two pieces together let me just say one
thing though the most important thing is
the social distancing and washing your
hands and we don't want people to get an
artificial sense of protection because
they're behind a mask because if they're
touching things remember your eyes are
not in the mass so if you're touching
things and then touching your eyes
you're exposing yourself in the same way
so we don't want people to feel like oh
I'm wearing a mask I'm protected and I'm
protecting others you may be protecting
others but don't get a false sense of
security that that mask is protecting
you exclusively from getting infected
because there are other ways that you
can get infected because the
asymptomatic and mild cases that are out
and so this worries us and that's why
the debate is continuing about the mask
because we don't want when we're trying
to send a signal that every single
person in this country needs to stay six
feet away from everybody that needs to
be washing their hands constantly and
know where their hands are to send a
signal that we think a mask is
equivalent to those pieces so in the
when the advisory comes out it will be
an additive piece if it comes out rather
than saying this is a substitute for and
we want to make sure everybody
understands it is not a substitute for
the presidential guidelines that have
already gone out and to be vapp salutely
clear about that we're seeing that
experts are saying that a high number of
these tests could be producing false
negatives so a guy Roshan abacus
many as one in three tests might be
dividing false negative maybe that would
almost be impossible without having 35%
positives you if that was true you would
have a hundred percent positive or 66%
positive so what I can tell you is the
number I'm not sure about that math
tracking very closely with the number of
cases diagnosed so I don't it would be a
third of the negatives so that math is
bogus math they're trending exactly in
the same way and that's important when
you're validating to really validate
does this same site in other words I'm
looking between testing sites to see she
doesn't claim to be a mathematician
they're an anomaly to make sure for what
you just very specifically asked so I
will go back and look at it more
carefully I haven't seen that kind of
anomaly this is the same platform as
being used across the country and that's
a range from what I reported 3%
positivity up to 35% positivity and that
range reflects also what we're seeing
with the hotspots and the number of
cases and frankly I mean we hate to talk
about it but it also tracks with the
hospitalizations independent of
diagnosis and the mortality that we're
seeing so all of those pieces validate
together like people might be getting
security or that we might not be seeing
all of the data here on deposit well I'm
telling you I'm still missing 50% of the
data from reporting I have 660 tests
reported in we've done 1.3 million so
there is and it could be those sites so
we do need to see the bill said you need
to report we're still not receiving a
hundred percent of the test sample
collection took one-minute results
reported back in 15 minutes I realize
you're the President of the United
States but when will everyone get to
take a test that works that quickly and
you get results that quickly so these
are new tests and we have prioritized
the groups that we think have the least
access to testing now and who do we mean
by that we mean the Indian Health
Service they're often in remote areas
rural areas the governors of the
northwestern States that may not have
the advantage of these high throughput
machines that are often across the East
Coast and in high metro areas Colorado
and then across the west coast so we've
prioritized the presidential 15-minute
test to the Indian Health Services and
Public Health labs so that they can
support nursing home testing and other
areas I really want people to understand
that the 15-minute test the machine can
do one test at a time right so it can do
four people per hour so if a place only
has one machine you actually need to do
the math as to whether in total you're
really getting more results I'm glad you
asked that because today there's 18,000
of these machines there we go already
out there we're trying to find out
exactly where everyone is because you
can see that gives you amazing
flexibility because if people would
allow it to be loaned to a state that's
in a hot spot or a state where you want
to do additional surveillance 18,000
tests 18,000 machines is a huge amount
and it really gets to your very question
about how we can prioritize what we have
at the same time we're moving out what
is new and so really figuring out who
should those go to how can we ask
communities because these will be in the
community to share those machines into
the community who need the testing now
and I think that's really an incredible
question that really needs to be
answered over the next 24 hours
when clarity about the faces covering
guidance you said it's still a point of
debate you said they'll use the phrase
that guidance if it comes out is the
guidance coming out and what my guess is
they'll say to try to avoid the hoarding
and people going crazy if you have a
mask you are advised to wear it but they
won't say definitely go out and buy one
but people will anyway and then they'll
wash their hands of the hoarding when we
say no gatherings of 10 we're looking at
we wanted to be clear if you have a
family of 10 we don't want you to be
split up but we don't expect people to
be having dinner parties cocktail
parties I mean I know you've seen the
slope in the United States versus the
slope in Italy and we have to change
that slope we have to change the
logarithmic curve that we're on we see
country after country having done that
what it means in the United States is
not everyone is doing it so we're only
as strong as every community every
county every state every American
following the guidelines to a tee and I
can tell by the curves and as it is
today that not every American is
following it and so this is really a
call to action we see Spain we see Italy
we see France we see Germany when we see
others beginning to bend their curves we
can bend ours but it means everybody has
to take that same responsibility
as American this is president mr.
president got a quick follow-up on oil
please in your conversations with Russia
and Saudi Arabia did you have to make
any concessions to get them to agree to
cut their production like did you agree
to cut US production well we didn't
discuss that they want to do that it's
good for their countries and we did not
discuss that down to fire the captain of
the USS Theodore tells us after he
raised red flags about the Kovach 19
outbreak on his ship it appears as if
he's being punished for trying to save
the lives of the sailors and his command
we're gonna wait a little while because
I understand as a news conference by the
Secretary of Defense about that but you
know I don't agree with that at all not
at all not even a little bit yeah thank
you this morning you said once again
that New York got off to a late start
and they should have pushed harder but
governors and other state leaders say
they rely on the federal government to
assess the situation and how risky it is
and they want to know how would they
have known to start soon
without your guidance well they have
experts and frankly long after we came
out and talked about it look how would I
have known to cut off China I cut off
China very early and if I didn't we
would have a chart that you wouldn't
believe so how would I know to do that
how would I know to cutoff Europe I
could oh if Europe very early I mean you
have to make a decision people knew that
some bad things were going on and they
got off to a late start and some others
got off to a late start also but we cut
off China if we didn't cut off China we
would have been in some big trouble and
we cut it off and you know what we cut
it off way early go ahead I'm the
insurance point in a separate question
that came in from a colleague who can't
be in the room on the insurance point
who roll call is there going to be an
opportunity for insurance companies if
in fact hospitals are compensated for
uncompensated care are the insurance
company is going to also get compensated
for its extraordinary expenses that they
may have or they use assuming that cost
well we haven't discussed it but we're
talking to them you know getting them
not to pay co-pays in the case of the
big ones was a tremendous thing that's a
lot of money they gave up but we're
discussing that with the insurance
companies well let you know it'll be
pretty quickly yeah go ahead question on
Japan sir
they are expanding their entry ban to
include the United States are you
planning to take any similar action to
ban Japanese nationals from coming to
the u.s. as a result of this crisis well
we're looking at a lot of things and
we're looking at at different bands we
have more bands than anybody we think Oh
cards weren't fashionable if you
remember right at the beginning of this
administration was for different reasons
but we've had bands long before people
thought of bands when I did China it had
never been done before I was the first
one to do that's not a bingo card
according to what I read it all the
papers this had never been done this is
a terrible thing to do and four weeks
later they were all saying we're lucky
we did it so we're looking at it no we
heard that and I think it's fine that
they do that they're trying to protect
their country and we have to protect our
country that you know decision should be
left in the hands of governors or if
you're considering and selling the
entire nation stay at home so just today
the Georgia's governor finally issued a
stay at home order saying that
individuals could have been infected
people before they ever felt bad but we
didn't know that until the last 24 hours
is that ignorance grossing he's a good
governor Brian cap he's a very good he's
a good governor and he has to make his
own decision on that I let the states I
think we're about 85% positive on that
if you look I think it's about 85% of
the states have got to stay at home
Brian's a great governor well not quite
a good decision he made that decision
ultimately he decided to go along with
it and they're doing and they're doing
well in the States doing well in many
respects not yeah go ahead please
couldn't make it in stay from Emily good
in the day we met the question in
regards to the Russian plane that landed
at JFK with medical supplies did the
United States ask Russia for this aid or
is it just accepting it we're accepting
it was a very nice offer from President
Putin I spoke to him the other night as
I told you and they had excess medical
equipment things and elements I'll take
it I'll take it I think it's very nice
we've had some from China
we also help other countries we like
doing that like I said before if we have
excess stuff we let it go out we let
some go out we're frankly they had
orders for it and I didn't want to stop
orders it was a very nice gesture on
behalf of President Putin and I could
have said no thank you or I could have
said thank you and it was a large plane
of very high-quality medical supplies
and I said I'll take it bring any
further aid in your honor I thinking
what have we asked for it
but it was very nice it was part of the
call he suggested he said we have it
it's additional well they have very big
difficulties with this virus also as you
know Russia I thought it was a very nice
gesture on behalf of President Putin I
could have said nota want it or I could
have said I'll take it and you know what
I said I'll take it except for the rain
I think if they sent things that we need
I take it nice gesture I'm not concerned
about Russian propaganda not even a
little bit he offered a lot of medical
high quality stuff that I accepted and
that may save a lot of lives I'll take
it every day please stay back
and you'll continue to stand with the
people of Iran given the fact they're so
hard to hit with the chronovisor oh
they're very hard hit very hard in a lot
of ways they're hard they don't hit in
with their economy with their military
and with obviously the virus they're
very hard hit would you consider easing
sanctions to allow medical supplies to
get in they haven't even asked us to do
that we know that sanctions hit the
people not the government in a lot they
haven't even asked us to do that if they
want to meet would love to meet and we'd
love to settle the whole thing out let
them out I doubt they'll be
realistically how does a person in
Tehran pick up the phone and call you I
think they love America
I think the Iranians love / I think
they'd love to be free I think I'd love
to have just some of the things that we
have you know I remember Iran many years
ago friends of mine were always in Iran
they were doing real estate deals in
Iran they were building beautiful
buildings all over Iran apartment houses
it was they were very successful and
then one day that came to an end but you
don't want the people of a red they
remember that it was a long time ago but
not so long ago they remember it and
I'll tell you they love America they
love what we stand for but how do they
call you and we're not looking for cheer
we're not looking for government take
over government change you know this
country has been through that many times
that doesn't work people do encourage
other countries to who are made
remember what I did yeah what I did is
you know I put it out very publicly with
respect to Iran I said if they need help
with respect to the virus we'd love to
said we have the greatest medical
professionals in the world would love to
see are you encouraging perhaps to to
lend their support because there are
many countries that are encouraging and
discouraging they've been a very hostile
country they made a deal that President
Obama should have never made long-term
deal giving them one hundred and fifty
billion dollars giving them 1.8 billion
dollars in cash Green Philip this last
time do you have a world responsibility
I have a moral responsibility to help
them if they ask if they if they needed
help I would certainly consider
different nations says they need help
well that's up to the United Nations I'm
talking about us and what happens is if
they wanted help because they have a
very big case of virus a very very big
case it one of the worst on earth I
don't know that this is the best line of
questioning right now I happen to
believe what I see and what I know and
if they wanted help we'd give them help
yeah you had one in the bag area to you
talked about
eating data from these different states
and regions to try and figure out what
they need how is she back in the room
and she was picked out yesterday because
she doesn't have a seat and the White
House Correspondents Association said
she's not allowed in anymore and she's
back again so the first the first issue
that we've been dealing with was really
the ventilators that was the number one
number two and number three from all the
states what we've been finding is that
people have a lot of these requests
based on the models and what we've been
trying to do over at FEMA is say to the
states well if you would like
ventilators we need to see first look in
your state's right so for example in
northern Jersey they're going down to
southern Jersey and they're finding
ventilators and trying to relocate them
to where they have their hotspots the
second thing that we've done is we've
asked them to survey for alternative
ventilators dr. Berg spoke before about
the anesthesia machines and the ability
to to convert them to be ventilators so
we're asking people to be resourceful
inside their states before they come to
the federal government the third thing
we've been asking States to do is to
provide what their daily utilization
rates are so everyone's asking for
everything one congressman got a call
from his local hospital saying I need
250 ventilators and he said well you
don't have a co good patient within four
counties why do you want 250 ventilators
and he says well we just want to be safe
we're very nervous right now so what you
have all over the country is a lot of
people are asking for things that they
don't necessarily need at the moment Oh
God job of FEMA called even compare
rough jack has been to try to make sure
that we're getting the real data from
the cities from the states that we can
make real-time allocation decisions
based on the data and right now what's
happening is a lot of the different
cities and states are providing FEMA
that that information we're talking to
them daily they're updating that
information daily and that's enabling
the federal government to make much more
informed decisions on where they
position ventilators you also have a
situation where in some states FEMA
allocated ventilators to the states and
if in instances where in cities they're
running out but the state still has a
stockpile and the notion of the federal
stockpile was it supposed to be our
stockpile it's not supposed to be state
stockpiles that they then use so we're
encouraging the states to
sure that they're assessing the needs
they're getting the data from their
local local situations and then trying
to fill it with the supplies that we've
given them the same thing with the masks
so the n95 mask is actually an item that
wasn't used as frequently in the medical
profession before this it was used
mostly for diseases so speaking to a lot
of the doctors and hospital
administrators they would say they used
actually a very low percentage of the
m95 masks with the president the
vice-president were able to do with
Congress was to get the waiver so that
you could expand the pool because a lot
of the masks were used to defer the
construction industries now there's a
much bigger pool of masks in the country
there was a stockpile they distributed
that based on where they anticipated a
lot of the need would go but a lot of
that still is stuck with the states and
it hasn't trickled down to the right
places within the state so I would just
encourage you when you have governor's
saying that the federal government
having hasn't given them what they need
I would just urge you to ask them well
have you looked within your state to
make sure that you haven't been able to
find the resources unlike other
countries a lot of the medical system in
America is a private it's not a it's not
a public government controlled so you
have to get the data from what's in
their state look at it in that way and
then make sure that they're being
resourceful in a way to do that and also
ask them what their utilization
percentage is because if one governor's
asking for more ventilators and if the
federal government sends them more than
they need the goal here is not to have
ventilators sitting in a warehouse where
you have another state where you have
people who need them so what we're
trying to do is make informed
data-driven decisions both on
ventilators mass any other supply we can
get to make sure it's going to the
people who need them so he says they
used to only use n95 masks for diseases
I see unnamed White House officials that
described your role as being something
of running a shadow task force how do
you describe your role how you how you
describe to the qualifications you bring
tomato material
yeah I would just say very simply look
the president asked the vice president
Trump's vice president asked me to
assist I've been serving really at the
direction of the vice president he's
asked me to get involved in different
projects the vice president I speak
probably sometimes five ten times a day
but everything that I'm doing is that
the direction of the vice president if
some people are talking to you that
means they're probably not informed as
to what's going on but I can assure you
that I'm speaking with dr. Burks dr.
Falchi the vice president and the
president multiple times a day to make
sure that I'm accomplishing and focusing
on the objectives that the vice
president deems a priority what triggers
sending a ventilator from the national
stockpile to a state in other words race
coach does somebody have to be to get
one of these national ventilators well
that's not the issue that worked that's
not the criteria you have the states
basically putting in the request and
there's giving us their utilization good
their utilization percentages so it's
it's a very simple formula the states
should know how many ventilators they
have in their states and by the way some
governor's you speak to our senators and
they don't know what's in their state
you know some governor's I'll speak to
and they'll know to the number how many
ventilators they have in their state
because that's the first thing a good
manager will do what a lot of the voters
are seeing now is that when you elect
somebody to be a mayor or governor or
president you're trying to think about
who will be a competent manager during
the time of crisis this is a time of
crisis and you're seeing certain people
are better managers than others so what
I would say is that the way that the
federal government's trying to allocate
is they're trying to make sure hey you
have your data right don't ask us for
things when you know that when you don't
know what you have in your own state
just because you're scared you asked
your medical medical professionals and
they don't know you have to take
inventory of what you have in your own
state and then you have to be able to
show that there's a real need and so we
pre-positioned a lot of things because
most governor's off the bat didn't know
what they needed but FEMA has a Joint
Command with Admiral of check Admiral
Joe wah
and peeking or where every couple hours
when their requests come in they
evaluate the requests they all vote on
the requests and then if there is
something that they want to elevate the
task force they bring it to the vice
president to make a recommendation
literally tracking hospitalization cases
on a daily